pourquoi on a besoin d'un avocat de
chicago ue est spécialisée en négligence
criminelle négligence criminelle
quand il ya des morts il faut un
responsable et il ya eu six morts
quelqu'un doit payer je vais voler cet
avion sur le don vous imaginez ce que
c'est vous avez une idée de ce que ça
représente
oui j'ai écouté les enregistrements de
la boîte noire hier soir vous avez
écouté vous êtes pilote nous non pas du
tout alors vous savez pas de quoi vous
parlez là venons en au fait à quoi on
joue là vide
dis moi ce que tu as à dire les équipes
du ntsb collecte également du son des
cheveux et des échantillons de peau
selon le rapport initial
vous aviez de l'alcool dans le sang
merci je vois pas le rapport
c'est pas parce que j'ai bu quelques
bières le soir qui a précédé les oignons
les conclusions de ce rapport vous étiez
ivre et si en plus il est prouvé que
votre état est la cause de la mort des
quatre passagers on va se retrouver avec
quatre accusations pour homicide vous
risqueriez la prison à vie
quand je vous ai rencontré j'avais peine
à croire qu'il puisse exister un tel
[ __ ] de poivrons et ouais on
remercie lui j'ai fait des recherches
commandant whitaker
j'ai lu ce que les experts ont conclu et
je peux vous dire que je suis
impressionné par votre talent
l'aef aa et le ntsb ont choisi dix
pilotes les ont mis dans des simulateurs
ont recréé les conditions qui ont
conduit l'avion a piqué vers le sol et
savez vous combien ont été capables de
poser leurs appareils
il y en a pas un tous les pilotes se
sont crashés en un rien de temps
ils ont tué tout le monde à bord il ya
que vous pouviez le faire chouette
bon je rentre